se nos pregunta qué fracción se
encuentra en el punto en la recta
numérica y aquí podemos ver el punto a
pausa el vídeo y trata de responderlo
muy bien hay muchas maneras de pensar en
esto podemos ver que el espacio entre 0
y 1 se divide en uno dos tres cuatro
espacios iguales y este punto está
después de tres de esos cuatro espacios
iguales que hay entre 0 y 1 esa es una
forma interesante de pensarlo otra cosa
que nos puede ayudar es una
visualización si este rectángulo
representa un entero y fíjense que va de
0 a 1 para poder verlo como un entero y
lo hemos dividido en cuatro secciones
iguales de modo que cada una de estas
secciones iguales las consideramos como
un cuarto entonces este es un cuarto
este es otro cuarto y este es otro
cuarto así que cuantos de estos cuartos
han sido sombra 2 bueno son 3 los que
han sido sombreados y cuando miramos la
recta numérica observamos la misma idea
veamos que el espacio entre 0 y 1 se ha
dividido en cuartos entonces este es un
cuarto y luego otro cuarto otro cuarto y
otro cuarto y donde está el punto a
bueno hemos pasado un cuarto dos cuartos
tres cuartos entre cero y uno que es un
entero así que qué fracción se encuentra
en el punto en la recta numérica tres
cuartos
hagamos otro ejemplo aquí se nos dice
qué punto se encuentra en dos sextos de
la recta numérica pausa este vídeo y
trata de resolverlo antes de que
trabajemos juntos y les daré una pequeña
pista imaginen que este rectángulo
representa un entero observen que está
dividido en seis secciones iguales de
modo que cada una de esas secciones es
igual a un sexto y si empiezo en cero
cuantas secciones llenaría para obtener
dos sextos y cuál sería el punto
correspondiente en la recta numérica muy
bien hagámoslo juntos así que si cada
una de estas secciones es igual a un
sexto y tenemos seis sextos aquí de modo
que esto sería un entero y esto es bueno
porque va de 0 a 1 y podemos verlo como
un entero entonces aquí tenemos un sexto
y luego tenemos dos sextos y podemos ver
en la recta numérica que lo que nos
lleva a dos sextos de camino a un entero
es el punto b corresponde a la cantidad
que hemos llenado en este rectángulo
el punto b justo aquí ahora otra forma
de pensar en esto es que se puede ver
que el espacio entre 0 y 1 se divide en
seis secciones iguales una dos tres
cuatro cinco seis secciones iguales y
queremos ir a dos sextos dos sextos
entonces cada una de esas secciones
iguales aumenta en un sexto de modo que
vamos de cero a un sexto y a dos sextos
una vez más terminamos en el punto b